[Music]
the good the bad and the just plain
weird
here are the most memorable moments of
the 2017 MTV Video Music Awards
Kendrick Lamar brought the fire
literally when he kicked off the show
not long after Taylor Swift unveiled her
highly anticipated music video for look
what you made me do hugest diamonds
dominatrix and deprecation oh stop
acting like your oh nice you are so fake
host Katy Perry sure can rock a space
suit but her opening bit didn't exactly
bring the laughs fans were also angry
after singer Julia Michaels was cut off
midway through her performance we can
always count on the VMAs to deliver the
unexpected during Kendrick Lamar's
opening number we saw a ninja completely
engulfed in flames music producer Jack
Antonoff was hungry can't blame the guy
for nibbling on a banana during the
telecast and Lorde proved if you can't
sing just dance
[Music]
the singer tweeted she was so sick with
the flu she needed an IV which explains
why she opted for an interpretive dance
instead of live vocals
[Music]
you